[Music]
please be advised please be advised
spoiler alert spoiler alert hello
everybody welcome to the Wonder Woman
spoiler episode number 55 and thanks to
you patreon subscribers you dying this
happens oh my god you guys got us over
the thousand dollar level we're doing
two of these a month now this one is
being recorded in the garage because ATC
was already booked but from so there's
no video on this to go up on patreon or
on the YouTube channel but sorry
Kimberly they were booked I take it
personally
but so we're back in the garage the air
conditioning turned off it's gonna get
hot so we'll borrow through this before
I get to I too warm but we want to bring
back to the show she hasn't been on a
couple years she was one of the
producers on ear buds our longtime
friend runs a Hollywood shorts and a
million other things miss Kimberly brown
hello everybody
if you work an independent film in LA
you've met Kimberly Brett that's a good
thing or that thing on this who
literally came from a panel or something
that you have a did I was speaking at
the dances with films panel was a panel
um nice filmmakers
Oh while I fasted dances assault which
basically turned into code for a
distribution panel basically yeah yeah
kind of disintegrated quickly and
hahahaha so what happened did you make
any money off your movie how do I know
the distributor's legitimate you know
definitely ask each other every Tuesday
knowing yeah yeah exactly the answer the
conversation we just had before I was
like oh yeah yeah I'm talking about this
like I said and they
you never know any of those ever
quarterly
they could come maybe not goodness what
else have you been doing gosh I am just
coming back to my senses from my first
year programming the Tribeca Film
Festival holy [ __ ] what was that yeah
that's a nice promotion I've been a
screener for them and last year was
offered a full position as a programmer
there and it was pretty badass lots of
like the stuff that's a really cool
stuff - what - like it's a great
association it's you work your ass off
and it's a big ass fast you know enemy
dead right it's like one of those fests
where there's how many food oh my god
for theaters volunteers shirts all that
I mean it's a very well my big eye exam
let's go right [ __ ] right yeah I it
good a Napa Valley is the food the food
is God Napa has got good food Norlin
Film Festival gives it a run for its
money an absolute is dope but yeah
Trebek at Chelsea immediately you know
so it was just um it's a different level
it's a different type of tone than LA
Film Festival when I was programming
there so it was a really great mental
adjustment which it's a different tone
different fest different different
caliber all together how many movies are
you program okay so everybody put on
your big-boy pants here so the shorts
this year got almost 44 hundred short
submission oh my god we take 57 short
film Wow
there were about 2,300 feature
submissions I think and we had 98 99
features so it's a brutal brutal brutal
world out there my friends it's tough
it's tough so getting that festival
rejection letter is not a testament or a
statement about the quality I mean yeah
your film I talk it might be why we did
program
and but not necessarily just wasn't room
it's just literally that you know if a
programmer is emailing you insane listen
I watched your film we'd loved it we
just didn't have a place for it I'm
telling you there are films that we saw
that will be on Oscar shortlist or that
are going to go on and win big big fest
we literally just didn't have room for
right
it just said the nature there's so much
inventory now digital has made it easy
for us all to make whatever we want
whenever we want right
and so the but festivals aren't we're
not doubling our not every cell whole
Seattle when I joined month-long
festival we didn't change our days still
do in four days or seven days yeah you
didn't go from a hundred slots to three
hundred November right yet not yet this
is twice as many festivals right so
that's the other side of the coin yeah
so it's been great and I'm kind of
getting back in the groove of Hollywood
shorts and we'll be starting our 20th
year the fall oh wow congratulations I
know what year was your first short film
Chris Mancini oh gosh
did we play hit clown for skins we
played skin first which was my first
year would 98 so it was probably yeah
and then I went back and graduate it was
the same year as I am we may be cousin
love that would yeah oh god stretch
marks or Attica Hyde are you kidding me
we've been doing at the lifetime right
Matt Joseph leaving at SRI night leaving
yeah right
sure so yeah so dancers with films this
is their 20th year Wow we all start at
the same time good advance me a long
long time yeah it's been a long so let's
talk about it let's talk about wonder
why we have a song
[Music]
research for two days let me say this
now to anybody tuning in for the first
time this is a spoiler app which means
we're going to only talk about the
Wonder Woman movie that just came out
with gal gadot and we're going to give
up endings key plot points so if you've
not fries movie hit the pause button get
the [ __ ] over to a theater and then come
back you're back alright so Chris and I
already talked about it a little bit on
the regular episodes episode 373 with
Laura Swisher we both liked it what did
you think I loved it
yeah loved it there are elements of it I
could tweak about just from a filmmaking
standpoint sure but as a chick that was
you know raised in the 70s maybe he'll
grow up in DC where Linda Carter would
be at different things and in a society
pages
yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes-yes like
bring your kids bring your nieces bring
your friends it's just it's it's doing
really well to content-wise story-wise
the overall what you're signing up for
I find that when on the journey and had
a good time yeah I feel like yeah we
didn't talk about this is good he
brought up the Lynda Carter secret Lynda
Carter TV show because I love that show
I remember watching that as a kid I
loved it I because I remember the spin I
give this about the teachers use to spin
that the crazy plane I miss the plane
but you know what I mean they're gonna
get in and I mean the truth what rope I
mean Lynda Carter
I was a kid who just loved seeing we
talked about it in the regular episode
so growing up and you know I uh it was
easy to find heroes that looked like me
or giant or men you know just male
heroes just even in sports you know I
grew up I loved Muhammad Ali I loved you
know like anyone that was a badass that
was like fighting for justice I watched
police woman as a kid because I loved
cop shows right and I was like bring it
I'm down so when when Wonder Woman TV
show came out I was like awesome another
superhero fighting bad people yeah so
but but what is so cool about this is
like
you say young girls were like oh my god
this is awesome but I think that the
real testament that I got was Chris you
talking about your daughter
yeah was like oh this is cool it wasn't
such a big deal fur which is that's
actually a great bet on progress that's
the progress that's the openness of it
Raj was like no way yeah I never thought
he's been growing up with good luck
charlie and yeah Disney shows that all
of shake it off and he'll have female
leads so to her it's not as shocking
that you know a woman would be star in a
feature film as a superhero so but it
like RAM and Isis both said we really
love this film it was really great the
tone was great it was funny it was white
like we said yeah it's good yeah funny
right yeah I wish I had the right tone
it was you could tell was lightened up
and it wasn't like a forceful end up
like Suicide Squad where they went back
in taking me and yeah yeah let's just
add some joke I'm very dark turn yeah
moving in my god well now it's just
worse so well done visualization
maintained it tried to be cartoony in a
way it was definitely superhero know
very early yes yeah way that they chose
to execute the effects like those Feliz
why he protects it was right Anna
it was cartoony Indiana Indiana Jones II
it really felt like we ride a bike
through syrup go back I loved it yeah
this is the thing that I you know like
to give Zach Snyder credit for he
created these type of that type of
slow-mo framing from the 300 that
arrives that was using this and it was
used in this correctly exactly because
like the opening fight scene on the
beach yeah it was like the fourth yeah
it was great so I'll try it out of the
gate man you like boom when short-grain
jumps up yeah on this one a shield and
they go jumping she jumped up on the
shield has three arrows and is like
that's the most badass like I just like
and I wanted it slow you want it right
yeah all that [ __ ] down yeah see for me
matrix was my first right kind of moment
that elevator seat of just stop and drop
and kick your ass right and so coming
out of the gate just ramping up I think
it was like the fourth or fifth shot of
the film was great giggles this is the
film we're giving you and it's going to
be full of these opening shot is badass
women training to fight right wasn't it
great right for a war that they know is
come they know was come on and I was
just like and the casting beautiful like
I'd love to know specifically like how
many of them have Olympic medals like
I've every recognizable faces in there
my favorite thing is I was watching
house of cards until the crack acid dawn
today so it was extremely mental cue
like watch a house of Christ episode
this morning at like you know seven
o'clock and then go into you know the
theater
straight after and and there's Robin
again yeah the last episode of house of
cards Robin right not pen no Robin yeah
yeah mMmmm so the last shot of house of
cards was literally her breaking print
right front spoiler alert site so um so
literally the next shot of the next
thing I watched was Robin could you is
like wow when I'm again being a badass
yeah and one of the things I wanted to
mention I didn't want to mention this on
the regular episode is that you know it
mess with the mythology a little bit you
have the Greek gods but in the in the
stories and more towards your stories
the guys are all still alive and wonder
woman's father is actually Haiti right
and so they actually they have a Wonder
Woman with the Queen how do you tell
that that so that was what was
interesting it was like you know what
this is okay because they may have
changed the origin and changed that part
of the story but they didn't change the
DNA of the character that's what I
haven't been able to get right until now
they did character remain the same so
you can change yeah you know certain of
parts of those details she's still a
half yet she still half immortal she's
still
new and you know going into this new
world fish-out-of-water type thing to
hide her reality from her a little bit
like that yeah right hell her mom's
afraid to tell her or her own protection
that always present origin story so the
other thing to it Chris you bring up a
great point which is I I agree like I
don't have a problem that they make some
changes provided they're sticking to the
decor of who the characters are right
and they're using like you know
Christopher Nolan used all of the source
material time Batman - thank you broke a
couple of things but it wasn't like
egregious right you like them you didn't
change Batman's DNA Batman wasn't a
killer right oh yeah uses a gun or
Alfred wasn't just a mechanic yeah or
brings Vicki Vale in the back camera
like that were committed yeah you know
consciously yeah it was like it was it
was awesome and Wonder Woman now can fly
so but they didn't they didn't actually
show that here in the film and in the
comics she can she can fly yeah but
originally she was in this in the jet
yeah it's me invisible jet I'm having
this a sequel issues I did miss the
plane right yeah yeah I liked I liked
how they showed but then the retconning
is like no she can fly like Superman
right I like yeah but he's learning
she's learning right yes that was the
cool thing love that was great origin
story so they took these things that are
very standard parts of a superhero movie
but good yeah did it the right way right
in just like well we have to have one of
these scenes it's like no no we need an
origin story I need to see her try to
figure out her new powers I've seen that
done a million times but again it was
done interesting it was done true to her
character and where she grew up
she's defying her mom and she's trying
to jump up to get that sword show she's
almost bucking I'm gonna just try that
just showing her into who she is I'm I
was born a badass I've been trained to
be one and I have superpowers but I was
born with something in me that says you
know what I think I can jump over that
ravine to get to that goddamn castle
yeah you know like that's who I am yeah
and they didn't they also didn't waste a
lot of time we see her as a young girl
we she was ready we fear it like 14h
efficacy your play with accents each
segment that was amazing yeah yeah I'm
like okay you're good actor got it yeah
I think yesterday I was speaking with a
filmmaker who was kind of discovering
how much motivation or a reason to
somebody have to do something that will
put them in conflict with their family
or put their kids at risk
don't you have to show reason like they
need money or they're desperate for them
and when you have a spiritual calling
and this really tapped into what we were
talking about yesterday because the girl
just knew somehow even before she had
vocabulary there's a magnetic force
field that that's cool and that's what I
want to do even but and so I thought
they were really exquisite about
establishing from jet she was like that
she keyed on it she focused on it she
was willing to break the rules for it to
be who she is and I think it really
reinforced his conversation having about
if you have a character that really is
well designed and X in the audience
buying in to this is their calling this
is what they were born to do and they're
just figuring that out the audience is
going to go and you don't need all the
manufactured plot points oh thank you
said frolic like I'm a priest I believe
that God made a calling that should be
good enough if your actor knows what
they're doing especially let's talk
about the caffeine in this movie yeah
the casting I loved it I knew as I said
before I I loved 90% of it I was new I
was skeptical of gal gadot for yeah sure
I shot you know the way Wonder Woman has
been drawn she needs to be bigger like
it was like when they cast Michael she
could be an Amazon ah yeah
as I Gail Godot is san like she's a
little girl my little girl I'm like I
need Lucy Lawless my life boom right so
I was not convinced of this at all and
I'm like okay I've seen gal gadot you
know in a fan road she was in the
Israeli army and she's good-sized
against Chris Pine
really ahahahahahaha succeed yeah yes
even eligible to be in this film because
I asked that question
isn't there a quota on the crisp line
here oh the same thing this other actors
in Hollywood people I know love you
Chris yeah he got great job great job
yeah but going back to the casting thing
in what you said so the mom was cast
correctly Robin Wright's character and
tan all this stuff everybody like Robin
right defies her queen but it wasn't a
victor her sister I wasn't it wasn't
like it her motivation was justified she
was like look I'm not defying you on a
disrespect but you know your girl I get
it you're a mom and you're the crane and
I'm yeah coordinate but come on use your
daughter that's be like Jesus not kind
of doing the whole cross man yeah it's
like Hello loose you made her this way
and they keep hinting this like re well
she has some origin that we haven't
revealed yet and that Aires is going to
play a part somewhere you know Aires is
coming they keep mentioning him usually
only gods you know in in this mythology
that survived and he's the cause of all
the war so it was interesting to see
like as the war progressed like she's
convinced like well if I kill Aires all
the world stopped and then I Eve
necessary yeah that which was I thought
those were some great moments and also
great commentary about humans yes yeah
and like land when Ares finally shows I
was like well no they're kind of doing
it on their own I'm helping a little bit
but this is kind of their thing
now here's the thing that irritated me
is when Ares finally shows up okay
British actor in disguise I get it these
Ares shape-shift form it's fine okay you
know when he becomes Ares like okay well
now what's he going to look like
oh he's still going to look like a
teacher from Hogwarts no I want to see a
God of War I want to hear it for you you
know even if it was just from like you
know Hercules a legendary journey that
guy looked like Ares right yeah I didn't
mind it being British I just he looked
like a transformer to me hahaha at the
end let's talk about the end right yeah
why don't the big fight yeah
the last 20 minutes I didn't you tuned
out a little early I completely found
out because we barreled towards a big CJ
sequence that we didn't need oh and it
took me out of it I didn't need it
I loved having all that origin story but
it put us into a two-and-a-half-hour
movie right and so by the time you don't
have to spend all the extra effects at
the end you don't you don't have you
need that last minute I didn't care you
know it was hard to stay rooting for her
to that well because most of it was
actually in a weird way grounded a lot
of the film was it was grounded the
reality of the ours of war yeah even
though this basically in aunjanue coming
in yeah right help even though she's
hero but then you get into all the CG
and the gods and you know it was almost
like a pact on this pit about okay
here's the perfect boys weird way like
there's some studio market and exactly
you know a big blowup thing at the end
of the boys and it was - because it was
so disconnected from the beauty of the
narratives because what had existed and
for that for her - being such a learning
curve about the world in her existence
and then all of a sudden is beast to
beast and you know what baby's gonna
hold like this I mean it's like Doctor
Who fighting some of darling being that
given node always been around for a long
time right but it's like some new orb
and probably Doctor Who it felt like
okay all of a sudden you know what I
found would have been interesting is
that this was going on in my head and
like and I knew they weren't going to do
it in the film is like what if the
commentary was Ares was never there at
all like this was the whole thing was no
this is war this is what mankind died I
know you're looking for Ares but he's
not here but I was there up into that
very bit that was kind of her learning
curve that was her big kind of emotional
turn and then it's all of a sudden oh I
am you know
father time I haven't Hallie said
whatever you know I was just like what
that's a that's it that is a great point
because the learning about and the
commentary about the human race yeah an
hour
constant state of war what was that
would have been a little more anymore
you and they bring Aires in sure he made
those he was making those Ramar do the
animal weapon and they'll be they'll
kill each other with it yeah you know
that was kind of interesting but I agree
it would have been probably better if
she would have realized how do these
wars end than Wayne is because they did
they picked World War one right but I
got with him to the water and all our
yeah and then it was a named World War
one no that's not what they called it no
I I thought it ended up defusing the
this kind of pure disney-esque heroic
turn at the end right when they have
that flashback moment where they're both
fighting to be the hero is going to take
out the plane and she realizes that love
is the greatest power of all and so
there's these great kind of soundbite
moments which are super cheese and
that's what I'm signing up for but by
the time we get to her having that
flashback in the revealed that he has
sacrificed himself and she now realizes
what the human love is like all her
girls bits are like oh you know is a
little I think it was I was exhausted it
was a little weird when I did like
kosumi tell the judge she couldn't hear
and then all of a sudden wait if you're
hearing return how could you remember
something that you didn't hear yes that
was a little rest and then it was just
to set up this great shot with Chris in
the plane with all the warheads right
and him having his hero moment by the
time we just felt like it so if the War
of the Worlds was HD well even
transformer party had been just a tiny
bit shorter right I could have stayed if
they're gonna build a grown a little bit
yeah cuz I didn't need the love story to
begin with I'm glad she got her first
kiss but oh my god I mean did I really
need that no yes we needed that I know
we had to have it
I'm just saying me personally could have
gone on her hero's journey right if
you're going to have that in there that
arc in there I wanted to just let that
complete and I felt like that kind of
war the worlds and
/ versus but she's going to really end
all what you know whatever that was
gotten away from me
I just wanted all the kind that could be
that I've just watched a lot of films
lately and I'm kind of last 25 years of
my life and maybe it's just like let's
go we know where we're going I'm having
a good time but I also like if I brought
my twelve-year-old nieces or nephews to
this do that you know and like the lads
a lot of movies a lot of mating it
wasn't a movie but it did move which was
good for sure and it was had a great
tone all the way through we were saying
that it was good and we were hosting
it's like I had my kids wait I'm like I
know there's going to be a teaser at the
end and there was nothing again I there
was another area I know yeah nothing
guardians of the galaxy Pacific sure I
never do them yeah like a whole short
film program it was like I get to dig
these out it pops SS and there's an hour
entertainment right those were great how
could there not be and there always was
on the DC once to this was like the
first one that didn't have anything yeah
they all did mom let's let's go into
some of the other characters that we
have we have a bottom in the regular
episode so like doctor poison let's talk
about doctor boy actor poison was she
really necessary for this film now you
didn't really get a lot of backstory on
her he didn't really get like a lot like
she just kind of showed up as like the
extra villain that was making poison and
occasionally a pick-me-up or the other
bad guy so I feel like - when you have
you have the boys at the bit what was
the name the bad general whatever his
name was
you had doctor poison then you have Ares
basically you have three villains that
are all kind of competing for screen
time even though one isn't revealed
little later
Ludendorff is ding in it like Angelica's
brother is looking pretty hot in that
uniform
she was a gettin played Ludendorff
that's that's Jonathan scientist and
delicous brother oh really I was like
you know of legend himself so for him to
be in this and he's kind of filled out
in his
you know he's aging well and as I kind
of mad as like it's an interesting piece
of trivia that both the actual ludendorf
in Hindenburg they both survived World
War one those actual January life oh
really died Wow four and thirty seven
that's really interesting we're about
doctor poisonous doctor poisoned for me
I thought was underutilized right right
hydrate dissipated I thought she was too
pretty
hahaha but not in a sexual way Jess it
when you have somebody that that's
mangled uh she seemed to dour and
especially powerful bitter angry care if
you're wearing that on your face it's
going to be horrific under D and then
when Oregon was like oh it's not wasn't
that why I was Hollywood it was probably
what ugly yeah I just I thought there
would be a more distinctive portrayal
and I thought they would she was going
to grow into this great nemesis which I
kind of under which never happened never
man offended but they ended up having to
have their confrontation at the end
right and it was just not sure and have
compassion for her and then try to
transform her and then it just really
was about but they couldn't have done so
I get it they couldn't have had both
altercations and they write someone I
mean really she had to have a
confrontation with three of the
characters pretty much yeah so I was
disappointed in that part but I loved
how her innocence of why should I sit
down or just being a woman in this world
oh yeah that is so important to me that
a lot of these women characters like
what do you mean I need to sit down and
be quiet again did they were just
unconscious into that which is kind of
like hopefully our kids are all like
those next world Janani me well there's
such great there's such great sentiments
in there when she's like there's the you
know English Parliament no women are a
lot yeah we're gonna do why is there a
woman here her own Purim hahaha
and then when she yeah I love as they
made it but what British to yeah yeah
well the other scene that was so
powerful was
she's talking to the jet they're like
fine we'll listen door you know they had
all the generals and she's like she's a
warrior and she goes you're a general
and you did a lot of battle yeah this
your troops colonel shame you have beat
yes dad and it was such a great
commentary I'm like oh a bunch of tail
political you know yeah a bunch of the
powerful people sit in offices while
your sons and daughters go die that's my
first thing that weren't happening later
exactly what's that seeing I had my
battle he did he didn't even I really
felt that's where she excelled as an
actor for me that I wasn't expecting I
knew that she could be the fiscal
partner in Israel but I thought she had
some really good meaty stuff because a
lot of those kind of moments would have
come off so clingy yeah and not and she
just those great kind of gender-specific
even the humorous ones just wouldn't
have worked unless you really had
brought some craft to it and you needed
a female director I really feel like
Patti JD ended a fantastic job be great
yeah I think she did great she's a woman
I think she great she's a badass
director well I think it was a mixture
of both I think because she had the
perspective oh sure being a woman sure
definitely helped but yeah but in a boys
club but you have a solid she had to be
a solid director oh yeah and so for me
my favorite retribution is the word I'd
like to use of being on set which will
remain nameless with a friend of ours
who shall remain nameless and somebody
on set
I got literally in an argument on set
and lost my mind and forgot like where I
was that I was there working the
president's the director it was like a
woman can't direct a superhero movie
it's never happened but I went on and
well mission when he might have been
talking about Punisher war zone hey life
is a sacred love like Lexi I love you
and so I seek gainer I love you too it's
beautiful film look beautiful nice shot
so okay uh I just was so when the
comment was made I literally forgot who
I was where I was you Austin because I
couldn't believe something
humanely singing I mean it's like if I
had been in film our show on Friday and
he had said something like that to me I
would have been like Oh holler like I'm
I'm sorry what
and I literally just went in for a bully
ominous guy like are you just added to
em sorry you have to we have to have a
chat and then quickly kind of try to get
my patch apologizes director and cuz I
realize it became a thing and it was
uncomfortable for us for the day no I
literally can't really aren't you the
peacemaker aren't you I own your face I
know cause the drama don't things that
done it was so outrageous and and
outrageous and I thought he was taking
the piss well surely he's just teasing
me cuz I'm the only grow on set right
right and I left and he was deadly
serious about his belief system about
women and directing and all the chat and
I was like it's the life of is that you
that you've had to hear that
I got eject like I love monster and we
were talking about Minnesota direct a
lot of TV yeah she drank a lot of tea a
- but like solid scripted episodic TV
wasn't doing keys is that right and
that's the things that we've talked
about so much when a good director who's
a good storyteller can cast and direct
actors I'm when they're given a hundred
and fifty million dollar budget they can
do a solid like I think Ryan's
conception like Oh only a certain type
of director can handle the giant budget
now I don't deny that there's a whole
nother minefield to navigate when you
got those kind of prices are but today
there's a lot that can - right and
there's a lot of people who have that
money and I just don't still don't know
where the money goes
Michael Bay get out of my head Graham no
because there's people like that Michael
Bay cannot direct a movie to say he he
can't cast he doesn't know how to tell a
story but he knows how to do big-budget
special effective profit so they'll let
and they can't making it he's a visual
effects supervisor it's what your dad's
doing brain surgery yeah
ha it's really you're really good at
this one thing but the fact that patty
Jenkins I'm glad I agree you need a good
director that knows how to tell story
but I think that it was important to
have a woman direct it yeah so that we
can get away from this a women can't
direct name one super movie that all we
made that was great well she's never
been given the [ __ ] opportunities
because Joss Whedon was attached right
what's the question he fell out so like
they weren't intending on this Venus you
know
led Petra obviously is somebody for
those of you who don't know I am also of
color
what and also um why is this boy we go
so again there's been so many decades
where we've heard as people of color we
can't directed his black people don't
come see movies or we don't know how to
director whatever the mishegoss is the
more that we have soul foods and you
know year after year after year we now
are really building on a good litany of
something that made a bunch of money to
the point where a moonlight could win an
Oscar at a million bucks and Ava's
making Selma's making a bunch of money
and she's doing a wrinkle in time she's
going to jail in time which is so
perfect in this legacy and then even
having get out to the kind of numbers
that in queueing helps every time I have
to go into these meetings oh well you
know if some would like to exited
mcclenney this conversation there's tons
of women directors but now hopefully we
can stop having to hear this archaic
conversation right like can't say
someone isn't good at something when
you've never given them the opportunity
right but there are women directing
stuff so to act like right the evidence
isn't there is is where I'm kind of
wondered I I read a great article about
it too saying it'll things will reach
parity when a woman can direct a really
shitty movie and then get to direct
another one and get to direct another
picture yes right because exact when we
know they're big it's a crap right that
it just worked workers workers work and
what societally is happening because
it's not just male producers who are
giving us
percent of all of the film's releases
here why do those hiring decisions were
made by women yes as well those are
women power brokers and women different
makers and women green lighters so what
is it societally that says of the two
hundred and twelve movies coming out in
2017 twelve of them are going to be
directed by a woman of a studio picture
that's the I'm sick of the conversation
I'm gonna be over here making my stuff
yes but we have to if it means this
movie making great amounts of money I
mean we can stop having this
conversation and we can just go in and
be on the directors lists I just want to
make sure I'm on the list
it's what the interview right Nana mean
no that's the boy I'd like to get to I'd
like to get to the place where everyone
is just like oh this is a good director
mm-hmm right and don't know every word
but it that's it you're a good director
I'm just looking at real yes exactly
show me your lips it's lime green and a
certain person from a certain background
because they have some insight to the
subject matter
let's have that I don't you know I'm not
necessarily the best director for every
female character her they're female
characters out there that some might
relate to more than others but I just
don't want because could get the job out
cut you know and some of the great
there's there's so many great examples
to support what you're saying like yeah
you know doing it for someone of a
certain gender ethnicity directive
specific story yeah maybe maybe that we
do but then a li yeah like you know what
I mean when he when he did ice storm
mm-hmm I thought there's no way a
Chinese person group in China right
Crouching Tiger Java yeah I'm not gonna
get this right I was like wow he told an
amazing American story so here's the
thing so what happened with Hulk yeah
again script horrible terrific
manuscript because all the data was
there there was no excuse for Hulk right
again there are all these comic books
that had the story in it yeah there's
plenty of source material yeah yeah that
like the sword rhetorics comics that's
when they always go wrong
I told I always [ __ ] up when they had
other dumb well this works in Hollywood
it's like they don't need it don't need
it I didn't mean it
yeah I don't need I know I don't need a
like but how insulting would have
Wonderwoman been if they added some like
you know mom I'm leaving the island cuz
it's alright like no no no she knows
she's the chosen one somewhere in her
body right mom knows it but her mom is a
scared parent how powerful of a queen
she is it was still human right it
wasn't weak female [ __ ] it was a
Scheinman
like reality parenting parenting I love
you and your that that great line I
think I'm gonna can't wait to use it in
my own family but today is the day that
you caused me my greatest sorrow haha oh
so awesome guilt-ridden fantabulous
taking away in the boat and the mom and
the horse and the truck and crisp by
Yosi of good sling yeah I'm not getting
in the middle of this I'm gonna try to
get the very making your hot daughter
with me they could kill me yeah yeah
yeah it was it was such it was such good
powerful stuff and and I wanted I want
to see good directors tell good stories
mm-hmm that's it yeah that's it like I
don't just and give everyone a shot
that's right if I want to show what
happens now eh how is the sequel not
already in production oh I'm sure it is
well I read something that patty Jenkins
was quoted as saying she was considering
doing a sequel I didn't read the article
but that led me to believe wait there's
not well I think what's going on is
they've got all these other movies on
deck that all the directors are leaving
from so you guys you've got Justice
League you've got one flash you've got
Aquaman yeah and we don't know how good
any of these movies are going to be
we're hoping we were talking about this
on the other episode this might be you
know the exception rather than the norm
these other movies may still be a mess
right now they still need some and then
it could be like where there's the group
and then the individual and then they
kind of alternate them right where are
we going to see Wonder Woman
okay can we talk about growing up as a
DC comic
and I left Marvel but I was a DC girl so
how can DC create their own I don't own
question but I want to know I'm at a DC
film as opposed to a Marvel film I don't
know you guys have had this kind of
conversation is it just this Glatt of
comic book based movies but I think like
Ninja Turtle had their thing and I don't
know that everything is feeling
homogeneous to me and no it's a bit of a
bummer it's definitely not it's been all
over the map
he's pictures why because there's so
much crap period well no I think it's
the wrong people steering the vision and
the wrong people in in charge of the
ship because what you what the the
vision was and it was a lot of X nighter
and his wife's vision really would
it was this dark bleak universe that you
know Superman who doesn't speak then you
know you have Batman who kills people
and you have all these changes to the
universe but they all share that common
core of just being bleak and dark which
is not interesting it's a mistake yeah
because it's not super Nolan made it
interesting you know those were very
bland dark yes Batman was a really
broken soul exactly yeah right right
right man is holy white man is it the
way you Superman you can't make it all
you can't make everything Batman yeah
you can't make everything Batman and you
can't make everything Batman and then
make it incorrect as well so you devoted
totally to go to your question look look
at what Marvel is done correctly
sure Marvel has an overall tone and
universe but they give each film that's
right each world its own it's something
don't feel it allowed Deadpool to happen
right which is even expanding their
their bubble over at Fox mm-hmm and look
at me a good Guardian we've talked about
this a lot on the show but guardians
before the first one was anyone
clamoring for a Guardians of Excalibur
he's now heard to me when I first heard
about it like I was terribly animated
yeah when I for a tour do diagrams
oh they're doing an animated Greg isn't
such a great idea a witness live action
wait why huh yeah what we're doing like
a tree and now I'm with the casting
what's my thing ma delivering so I think
DC like they state they've just so much
of what they were doing it was funny
because we always thought that Marvel
movies were awful and the DC ones were
better right and then more there was a
time where that happens was true but I
think it's because those were my heroes
I thought it was his I'm a little bit
older and they were my hero so those are
the stories I wanted to see yeah forget
there's a but there's at least two
horrible no three horrible spider-man
movies of which do you speak I have no
idea what you're talking about I am
white dude you might have sat under oh I
choose to your brain Star Wars prequel
absolutely and do you even like like I
can ask how many Punisher movies have
there been my for rate uh take three or
four at least three yeah Lexie's a third
there's been another one since and
there's going to be an episodic now yes
right because there's a Dolph Lundgren
one yeah that's a guilty pleasure that
first one you know what I miss Jane was
one how many ways so it was like I like
commenting in the punch I like him as
that character just the movie wasn't
good movie no but I liked him as that
character I loved the waves like he's
looked because Steve shot it right
I felt acne was off on that one I think
she takes a bad rap classroom encounters
it's through I think maybe there's three
end in the TV's the fourth renditions
perhaps could be but they're doing so
justice league is coming out this yeah
part two just got announced oh I thought
they canceled that I thought they were
only going to do justice league huh like
it was originally going to be two parts
and then it got compressed down to one
but maybe maybe they blew it back out
again a morning - Jared oh okay yeah
according to gal gadot's IMDB page she
is slated to be in Justice League and
Justice League part
okay hmm so that could be very
interesting and how the narrative then
has to be have a super art right for
these that whatever orders well then you
also have like the flash and Aquaman are
going to be in there somewhere too okay
what's interesting too is DC is actually
doing much better on television like you
have the arrow verse where you have you
have green arrow you have the flash you
have Supergirl and then you have a lot
of the supporting superheroes are in
there too like firestorm when it's a
black an area it is not they made it
very specific that none of them will be
the same they're loud Wheatly separate
that was completely different that's
that's keeping actors employed in Halle
you're gonna have two flashes you got
actually appear if you're gonna have a
green are you gonna have a got movie
green arrow and they have to do that
financially they would be so over a
barrel if they had to keep all those
actors happy for every it's a three
smart way to do it keep the TV cost low
well I mean what the way Marvel did it
was so smart is that you have the Marvel
TV shows they're related to the movie
but they're different there's no
difference yeah yeah so there's an
article I just want to say this Rick
into the conversation so Wonder Woman is
the biggest opening ever for a female
director and is pulled in 223 million
dollars worldwide just last weekend
that's fantastic that's you we said now
we're getting past this [ __ ] of oh
it's good numbers for a woman right haha
damn number it's just a great summer
opening and let's get down with that I'd
like to get to the point where I mean
she's probably thanking her lucky stars
like oh thank God I turned down the
Great Wall now finance addressed our I
wonder what that's like as we all love
our genre stuff when we all our commas
with fans but there are filmmakers out
there who aren't necessarily trying to
get into
world and I do wonder what it's like for
those who come from super cinematic
backgrounds that are trying to do really
current you know heavy cinema pieces
feeling like to be able to work they
have to get into some of this land where
there's more work well then they may not
be the right directors job I mean one of
the ways that these movies are
successful is you have directors that
are passion about those first two
spider-man movies were successful
because say Merman was a great director
and he loved you I love my term and and
he grew up and you know he had a passion
for fact you know the Green Lantern
movie was directed by the guy at the did
vertical limit right what was he care
right exactly difficult women yeah
that's the Charlie Sheen no known
everyone was at the Stallone mountain
climbing one yeah
that's along the ice year yeah and that
helicopter is really great for
typography it's just not something to
watch on the airplane yeah yeah I just
always wonder how these expansion of
these kind of films at these numbers you
know is what's the sustainability of
that what are we going to be making 300
million dollar films what the thing
we're getting close to what this holy
but going back to Wonder Woman so yeah
you know the Avenger movies infinity
where's probably gonna be one of the
most expensive movies ever recorded but
yeah those cats in America will be
during the two to 250 million yeah yeah
so is this considered a low-budget
before more hahahaha never Deadpool was
like what the only guy yeah Riley
million for yeah yeah yeah that's cause
Ryan was doing it himself and he's like
started back what that was like the
Kickstarter universe right
his little I really like this character
we let me do it up bring my own money
and sixty million is like low-budget in
that world so the ones I were to use
like but this story still the story and
the character journey silly character
right so so an effects you're cheaper
now and effects are cheaper but what
we're getting is 45 minutes a stunts and
warfare and you know and and at the same
time all of these visual effects like
when you go to Guardians
there's literally seven or eight minutes
of the credits that are just every
special effects company in four on the
planet yeah
and half of companies are going out of
business I'll explain I'm still not
understanding that what happened was I
like am i winning all these awards and
then literally went out of business yeah
they couldn't get paid right thanks acts
as that what movies winning awards yeah
cuz they're yeah me ask you this going
back to potential Wonder Woman sequels
really and we're so it's so set up right
where she's in the beginning of the
movie she's working in the Louvre looks
like and that's her cover
that's recover she's art historian or
something right and yeah a curator
curator yeah exactly of exotics
I'm excited exotics and she gets a
library's case from Wayne Enterprises
which has the photo yeah from so they
ended the movie then she goes back and
she's like you know dear Bruce thanks
for the photo brings back memories or
whatever I would do is even scooter was
thanks for bringing him back to me yeah
it's very like ah yeah yeah so what she
still aversion as far as I can tell so I
didn't think it happened in this next
one it's kind of first kid there that
you know the kid will be like what 1/4
God in Superman or her and bad I thought
no I heard Bruce Wayne or a thing and it
depends you know sometimes it's Superman
what issue what you're like yeah exactly
yeah so where is the comic what is what
is the Wonder Woman sequel based on that
I think it's going to be modern times
they're going to think they're gonna do
like a Captain America kind of thing
alright we did the World War one one
that Yount row now we're in modern times
and so but as far as what the conflict
will be I don't know I don't know what
how about right okay but I don't think I
don't think it'll go back in time I
think it'll be modern I want to mention
this real quick the scene where they're
in trench warfare and he's like look we
gotta go she's like no there's people we
got to do something now and he's like we
can't and she just goes nope takes off
the dress or the
the whatever gown or whatever she had on
full one woman out [ __ ] shield runs
across the battlefield and just like
takes fire and then all these guys go
her it was awesome and she's running at
[ __ ] bullets and rocky ass and all
these guys are just like the Scottish
guy but UN yeah a really great guy
particularly hilarious and that you know
ten minutes before you tell her to get
her female hands off of him I was like
oh I'll follow her forever you would
enjoy your life o'clock I love that
there were largest there was the obvious
when they meet her like oh hello cutie
like go play with your dolls and then
the minute they see her be a badass
they're like okay you're down with the
fight we're in I think one of the
moments like that that was great in the
movies when they were putting quote the
team together it was like alright well
he's like I can fight that's not the guy
yeah yeah I just again loved it was such
a great mmm kind of like going to church
on Sunday where you get that power pill
emotionally to watch that to remember in
your own day to not settle but well why
do I have to consider why do I have to
compartmentalize myself why am i second
you know because that character she was
so believable in those moments of why
are you talking me like this why
wouldn't we save this person right now
right here and it was so political at
the same time which I love in my onra
that's the whole reason to me and I'm
sorry but I'm sure they wrote this prior
to Trump but it's so things are so
relatable there were so many things that
are gonna try matter I don't know I I
think with everything going on in the
world anything horrible in a film or TV
show is relatable relatable right now I
think that's fine it's a quite a broad
you want I mean honestly
so crazy and yeah there's people on I
didn't
who was it that said this movie wasn't
American enough for something I don't
know that I'm sure there's
somebody's a commentary that she was an
American really there was there was a
tweet that said that that's weird
ha ha ha my Twitter yeah I said
something stupid on the Internet all
again with the accents yeah yeah I like
the GU America is currently in war in
seven or eight countries so the American
war machine is is been going on for a
while for decades and in anything so
this this commentary was amazing to me
because it was like look at this look at
what she just and just so like well why
would you do that and if you are going
to fight you wouldn't get in there too
and you're just with this we should go
help those people it was so because
that's where our world is at it's like
we're the richest country in the history
of the human race and why are we like
everyone what happened in Manchester in
London is awful it's awful but do you
know how many civilians we've killed in
drone strikes in the Middle East just in
the month of March well war Obama did it
I mean the world war is awful and that's
one of the points of that last movie
made which is good so it doesn't matter
I mean did I you know there's no and one
of the points that Chris Pine was making
it like you know this is like nothing
I've ever seen it's people are just
being killed all over the place right
and yet his character still was
well-meaning and well-intentioned and
how they are secure picture let's go get
the gas right however before that
character to still have the opportunity
to be like oh yeah and we can do both
bran can deal with the macro and the
micro yeah yeah oh I mean when you know
his like why you know I forget how he
said it but he was like I mean I gotta I
gotta go do this yeah you know you're
probably all gonna die but oh it's a
golden a when he took the lasso and
wrapped around himself to preview was
telling her the truth
I thought his performances anyone I
don't meet Chris planning every single
movie Hollywood but Brett he's a bigger
jar endeared him to me I thought the
sexual humor in the beginning like to me
I was like oh my god
but he was so good at it then it would
like I'm above average yeah kind of be
you never bought it because I'm shown in
the film and again going back to
Kimberly your commentary on Gale Godot
her acting was so solid that she was
believable when she was saying these
things that were obviously meant to be
funny or to you know ballbusting or
whatever like when he's making the bed
on the boat mm-hmm and she's just like
what you know I'm in my waiting you
sleep with me why would you sleep with
me but we don't really need you for
anything you know it's just a supersonic
no plan other than making babies we
don't need you for pleasure you're right
right but it wasn't like any other
pressure like man girls ready it was
just so when I hate fall it wasn't it
was so not you it was it was scientific
it was it was it was otherworldly yeah
unbelievable and that made it fun and
yet landed like she had to have really
that which is well directed to make that
tone work when that performance and a
cry was good caster yeah it was a good
chemistry between the character and she
had the physicality which I totally
believed and I think you had I think I
agree with you about Chris Pine does
mean everything but whoever it was
needed to be shorter than her yeah had
to be the only one taller than Ernie in
Superman I wouldn't it be bad like nah
man I haven't where II wasn't going to
lose though she needed she's an Amazon
and Amazon said taller than everybody
everybody and and whatever where are you
going to find a short actor in Hollywood
like no matter which mythology you
ascribe to the Amazon women are like
some earth science yeah and you're right
I thought like only Superman like looks
bigger you know he's the only one ever
drawn bigger than her is Superman it's
Superman
back Batman was birthday fries they're
kind of you even when you see them lined
up
Superman's always right Essen
a prank he is the a of the AOA and then
her and then ramen right which always
got which again goes to nine o'clock
right there which again goes to the oh
my gosh you're right and try this isn't
a video episode we didn't cut in this
great vintage more DC comics clock yep
batteries well any closing thoughts um I
want to give respect at the premier
little tidbit at the premiere of this
movie they invited Lynda Carter and when
the car was on the red carpet and you
can go online and see guile go up to her
and bowed down to Lynda Carter on the
red carpet in her gown and it was a
fabulous beautiful moment being really
excited about not just the movie but
knowing that the filmmakers were taking
such care to think to bring 'land in and
have her celebrate this moment and be
celebrated in the her legacy of this
character so it got me fired up and that
bad actress again points for knowing
respecting and and her contribution to
the legacy yeah my thing is all my
questions about DC and gal gadot being
cast are answered and I like I'm ready
to watch another two three more movies
of gal gadot just going out and kick I
like I'm in like the way I'm like wanted
I'm fired up for the Marvel Universe and
also now guess what Marvel it's been
thrown down to you when is your female
superhero movie coming it's Marvel
alright so get it get it out there just
now I'm on you now you are playing
catch-up right Marvel is playing [ __ ]
catch-up and they need to get on it so
they're it's definitely I don't know if
it's in production or not but it's in
it's on there suede you want black pants
on screen and let's say behind the
screen as well yeah let's stay behind
the camera as well Marvel could step it
up yeah for sure so I mean I really
enjoyed this film I was so happy to say
I really wanted it to be good and I was
really glad it was as far as you know
what's next for DC I can be cautiously
optimistic but
just going to enjoy Wonder Woman now I
know I don't know I'm not I tell you
what right now I'm more fired up for
whatever this Wonder Woman took a sequel
is versus justice right I know am I more
excited about them really yeah yeah for
the Wonder Woman completely because how
many I am Groot scan one to rely on to
get I can do what I might if hey I love
you great all right excellent you boys
yeah Thank You Berlin can anyone find
you on the Internet well yeah man hit me
up at Hollywood shorts and any platform
that you choose we are there and look
for I said the Palm Springs Film
Festival I'll be doing some panels and
roundtables and hit us up for any Film
Festival consulting that you need for
your movie oh there you go ah we can
attest firsthand she does a great job I
got into some great stuff I didn't want
to do the festival circuit I thought it
was gone to my grave it sit me down and
talk to me and I was like alright fine
and one of the I had two amazing
experience well a bunch of really cool
experiences the premieres SF doc fest
and showing the movie in Napa the Napa
film that was amazing the retreat was
amazing and being and you said I
remember you said to me I was like [ __ ]
one on Napa for you know and you were
like Ram this retreat thing you need to
be treated like a filmmaker because I
think I have such a like you know I've
come from such an abusive relationship
and comedy where radians are treated
just like shut up we're just so
relegated $25.00 really in the back of
your car yeah and I know you can do
something that 99% of the population
can't but I don't care you get the kids
table and we think of you know more than
a birthday clown and directors for
better for worse are given more respect
they just are even if they make a shitty
movie you're given more respect even to
each other even to each other yeah yeah
you're just like oh you and so to be in
that world that Napa that you were like
and you think you need to have that
experience you didn't get that with
laughs gana Stan and you were like I
know you're bitter about the festivals
because of how laughs gannis name was
treated and I was part of it I was like
you're right [ __ ] them let's just do our
own [ __ ] everything's do-it-yourself but
it was such a cool experience and was
treated so well and then like going to
comedy Cluj Romania man is so awesome
and like I say the dopest it was such a
yeah so a lot of filmmakers like wait
what you want me to go where and I'm I'm
telling you getting this pencil is gonna
rock you're driving around and in
between it like a can yeah and a BMW and
all these beautiful old theatres we
spend have been around for so walking
hundreds of years this cool town like it
was nothing fires you up to get busy on
your next film and who you are as a
filmmaker this is our food this is our
little palette yep and you need that
until you can go on these experiences
and not come out of there going [ __ ]
I make it next then you don't need to
make a movie but you know but in the
meantime we get so little of that
because it takes so long to make a movie
that you got it you got to have those
experiences that's what propels us so I
mean thanks for trusting me train no I I
try both you guys had talked to me and I
said to both you alright I I don't think
it's going to work but I'll do it and it
works and I'm so glad that you did so if
anyone out there is listening ya want a
film festival consultant I would hire
Kimberly Browning how are ya thank you I
love my boys oh and hopefully we'll be
making more movies we will now we have
information yeah well thank you guys so
much for watching
I got a listing actually and and thank
you so much for supporting the patreon
and we like we said before it's like you
know with the $10 tier is great but if
you can only do five or two it all helps
with anything anything helps and I'll
stabilize and grow the company and
you're getting to spoiler up some month
yeah we're giving you more stuff oh this
is it's an equitable trade so thanks for
some thanks for listening thanks for
supporting the show go to the
patreon.com slash slash
comedy grandma what's mine if you want
to donate to my support us on
youtube.com slash comedy film nerds
we're putting all new video up every
week you can see clips of what we do you
can see the atc studios you guys are
awesome and thank you for supporting
what we're doing and you're helping us
grow we're going to be doing more cool
stuff Thank You Kimberly brownies good
I'll see you guys at pie fast and yet
October 6th to the 8th yeah ah and we'll
be a Comic Con my name is grandma and
I'm Kris Mancini and as always remember
Han shot first Chris Pine